I want to take a second and sort of step back
from the micro of the virus and think a little
bit about the macro, because this is not getting
nearly the attention that it deserves.
One of the things that the virus has exposed
is just how fragile and precarious, not just
the American economy is, but how fragile and
precarious the entire planet's economy and
circumstances are.
And this is not an attack on any particular
politician.
There are many critiques to make of particular
politicians, including our own here in the
United.
Gates But this is actually a bigger picture
issue in sort of a realization that we have
to come to.
Yesterday, Donald Trump announced the U.S.
is invoking the Defense Production Act and
that we would be dipping into our stockpile
of masks and ventilators because the medical
system is so quickly becoming overwhelmed.
And remember, we're early in this thing.
We're still very early in this thing.
And it's important to know that that stockpile
is really met for a truly massive crisis that
is out of control in the models, something
way more serious than this virus.
Now, I want to be careful.
I'm not minimizing this virus.
This is a crisis.
We're doing what we can to deal with it.
We've been covering it as a crisis.
We've got a social distance, self isolate,
all of that stuff.
But I also want to make sure that we understand
that this is a stockpile that needs to be
there in case of something like without being
dark, a nuclear attack, a flu pandemic with
a really high death rate like think.
Fifteen percent, a very serious death rate
flu.
The fact that we're just in the first week
of when Trump finally stopped saying this
is no big deal and is being serious about
it and we're already dipping into the stockpile
that's meant to be there for those super crises.
This is a virus that, again, in the end is
likely to have a death rate under 1 percent.
Doesn't minimize the number of people that
may die.
I want to be really clear.
But what I'm explaining is once you account
for the real number of cases here, which could
be orders of magnitude greater, is likely
orders of magnitude greater than than the
official numbers.
The death rate may end up somewhere between
point seven and 1 percent.
And we're dipping into stockpiles that are
meant to be there for something far more serious.
This has triggered a likely global recession
and the stock market has fallen now below
the level where it was when Trump took office.
So we've seen a net stock market loss under
Donald Trump.
People are losing four one KS.
Thousands of people are dying.
We're talking about massive unemployment increases,
trillions of dollars in emergency government
spending.
And so to be really clear, this isn't about
minimizing the seriousness of this virus.
And in fact, we've been from day one making
sure we don't minimize it and that people
know it's serious and that we have to act
now.
But what I want you to consider is that if
things are this out of control now, we're
we're already dipping into these stockpiles.
If it's serious enough that I'm certainly
going to remember this period for the rest
of my life, assuming I make it out.
Just imagine what would be going on if this
was a more deadly flu, a nuclear attack or
some other major event.
We are incredibly unprepared and having an
incompetent president doesn't help.
But this is bigger than Donald Trump.
Even when we think about the bailouts that
are now correctly going to have to be done,
a lot of it relates to the structural liabilities
and the precarious nature of our economy.
This whole discussion about restaurant workers
who need to be bailed out, it's an accurate
discussion.
They need to be bailed out.
But if we had a better infrastructure for
paid leave for such restaurant workers, this
wouldn't be such an immediate crisis.
The declarations that Donald Trump and governors
had to make about we've got to change how
health insurance deals with the cost of testing
and treatment because this is an emergency.
All of that would be made irrelevant if our
health care system was more stable and sensible
from day one.
I said it yesterday and I'll say it again.
An ounce of prevention is worth a pound of
cure.
And it couldn't possibly be more clear than
with this current situation.
And the reality that we all have to understand
is this is a feature of our economic system,
not a bug.
It feels like a bug because now we're in crisis.
But this is a feature redundancy and being
proactive costs money.
If you just react.
It only costs you money when the you know
what hits the fan.
Warehouses, surplus staff, et cetera.
When the market plays too big of a role, this
is what happens.
That stuff is just too expensive.
When the private sector has too much power,
this is what happens now.
Although this isn't meant to blame Trump,
the entire world is to some degree underprepared.
We also do need to recognize that there is
blame here to assign.
And in the United States, one of our two major
political parties, the Republican Party, is
the one that believes readiness, preparedness,
that it's wasteful spending that also has
to change for good, because otherwise we're
not going to learn anything from this or at
least nothing that we will actually be able
to get consensus on and act on.
I don't know whether this fiasco will change
anything for the Republican Party.
They tend not to learn from mistakes, but
they should.
And then lastly, the other scary reality is
that the virus has.
Shows how unprepared the U.S. is for any kind
of biological attack as well.
And I know that, you know, we don't want to
add more onto what we're dealing with now.
A lot of us don't want to be thinking about
that.
But that is the truth.
And the goal would be you learn from mistakes
and then you become more resilient.
Nick Naseem, Nicholas Taleb writes about A.I
fragility in systems and at the individual
level, and he writes about black swan events,
two things that are very, very relevant.
Right now, I encourage you to check out his
books, which are very good.
It's not often what people want to think about.
But we need to be thinking about it.
And this has really exposed a lot.
And lastly, later in the program, this entire
crisis has significantly improved the climate
change situation.
And that is something I hope we will actually
learn from.
I'll deal with that a little bit later.
Let me know your thoughts.
We'll be posting about this on the David Packman
show Instagram page at David Packman Show.
Follow that and also follow me on Instagram
at David Dot Packman.
Later this week or over the weekend, I will
be doing a tour of the home setup because
we've decentralized production of the David
Packman show, fought for social isolation
purposes, social distancing purposes.
And I will show you guys it's quite wild.
What what what we've put together.